hey guys and welcome to another
moneymaking video today I'm going to be
showing you something that can be done
on a brand new account uh level three
although it is recommended to have a few
HP levels uh and what we're going to be
doing today is picking white berries now
this hasn't really been a viable method
for a couple months now because the
prices have been so low but now white
berries are up to about 1.3k each uh
which means that by picking the white
berries in Wilderness you'll be earning
about uh 600k an hour all you're going
to need for this is a UL of Glory
a uh looting bag and a knife pretty much
all right hope you guys enjoy and let's
get started all right so what we're
going to be doing today is uh picking
white berries and uh this is a pretty
well-known Money Maker so uh the price
wouldn't really be affected too much by
this um the reason I'm making this now
is because if we look at the price of
white Bears they were up to 1.3k each uh
was extremely high I mean the last time
it was even up that far was almost a
year ago they're up to 50 00 so they're
back up to a reasonable price of about
1,300 each uh we'll just price check
that quickly in the grand exchange just
to see what they're actually at at this
current
moment um and what we're going to start
off by doing is first I need a looting
bag so I decided just to include that in
the video just in case people didn't
know a good way to get a looting bag so
1348 that is really good uh so an
inventory of those would be worth close
to 80k or something like that uh so yeah
deposit that and what we're going to do
now is just go and kill some chaos
Druids
um killing chaid just because um they're
easy they're in level one Wilderness so
it's not very risky and um they actually
give you drops they're actually worth
something and they're good to train on I
mean you could go kill rats which are
objectively a bit easier to kill uh but
they don't have any benefit beyond the
Looting bag where the chaos Druids can
drop uh seeds and whatnot and yeah so
we'll go ahead and kill some and get our
looting
bag all right so we're at chaos stge
right now and this is why I like going
here is because look two Nar weeds easy
mode that's like 20K worth of drops
right there almost and uh while I am
using a blowpipe is not required at all
you can bring any kind of range gear or
lowlevel melee gear these guys are
pretty weak honestly and we'll just do
this until we looting bag again the
alternative is to kill rats in the
werness or you can even kill these
Bandits down here if you wanted but uh I
would recommend the chaos Druid just
because of the money yeah it's kind of
nice all right there we go guys we got
the losing bag uh probably only H
probably 30 to 40 kills which is pretty
average honestly so we're just going to
teleport back to Edgeville and we'll see
how much money we actually made add that
into the hourly total no I'm joking how
much herbs do we get in just that amount
of time like 30k or something that's an
awful so now we have the Looting bag and
now we can pretty much start the method
so now let's just Bank everything
here so you're not going to want to
bring almost anything all I'd recommend
bringing is a anti-fire
shield some energy potions or a dose of
stamina potions uh we'll bring some just
random doses here and uh we will want
the Looting bag of
course and you're going to want a knife
or a scimitar that doesn't weigh much uh
we could just bring this Rune Scimitar
but I think we're just going to bring a
knife just to save
on weight weight reduction a bit and a
knife so scrip The Shield Blum bag
energy potions and of course you want to
bring a little bit of food just bring 10
lobsters that might be a Overkill
okay let's go so from here all you're
going to do is run down to the
lever pull the
lever and now you're in the wilderness
now you're not really risking much I
would just kind of hustle it you don't
really you could log but if you see
somebody but honestly you're what am I
what am I risking like 10 GP okay 1.8k
of course you don't want to lose the
Looting bag so you do want to be careful
and you want to be mindful of these hell
hounds here as well cuz they can do a
lot of damage if you're lowlevel uh so
if you're low level you definitely want
to bring lobsters for better and um
because for one these hellhounds can hit
like 10 to 15 in the lava dragons can
hit pretty high um especially if low
defense so from here we're just going to
run all the way to the hole in the fence
down here all right once your fence open
it and then we're going to run a little
bit South until we get to the lav dragon
aisle once we reach the dragon Isle here
we're just going to go through the fence
of course be mindful of any PES here uh
again you're not really risking anything
but it still is a pain to get the
Looting bag and you don't want to do it
again so just run past the dragons here
um try not to get hit by them too many
times and we're going to run a little
bit here just to the right of the
agility
symbol and we're going to grab this
thing of white berries here this is a
safe spot so they can't grab you here
and all you're going to do is um stand
here they respawn in like two seconds
and uh that's pretty much it guys so
we're going to stay here until we get
the full inventory and toss in our
looting bag do it once again and then
we're going to run out of here all right
so I grabbed one inventory of the white
berries and there's another one in my
looting bag right now uh so we'll go
ahead and come back the exact same way
we came originally we're just going to
run back to the deserted keep and pull
the lever there and um so yeah each one
of these white Bears is worth like 1.3k
each 1. 1271 right now which is still
extremely good uh seem to be lagging a
bit right now
yeah so we'll head back to the Gran
change set off the inventory and get an
approximate time of how long it
took all right so we're back to the Gran
change and we did loot 53 White Bears
when we're in the wilderness so let's go
ahead and sell those off and see what we
actually get uh Dan is sold for 68k uh
per run and now that run probably took
us between 5 and 10 minutes uh we'll do
a an hour of this and then we'll be able
to know exactly how long it takes um
just one other thing worth noting is you
should bring an amulet of Glory uh
because the the lever unless you've
completed the hard or medium our Dune
Diaries uh will teleport you to already
or one of the Diaries anyway maybe it's
the Wilderness diary anyway you will
need a am of Glory most likely and uh
one other thing I'm going to be doing is
actually I'm going to bring uh some
Trident charges to just use on the lava
dragons while I'm there you can also do
this at a very low level which is fire
strike uh you will only get about one
lava dragon kill per trip um but since
you can actually pick up the berries and
attack with losing a tick it's actually
pretty efficient to just kill a lava
dragon or two while you're there uh
doesn't hurt you at all and I can always
get lucky you never know all right so
let's do this for an hour and we will
see our expected profit all right so
we're done and we managed to get about
450 white berries pretty average our
runs took about 7 minutes each uh some
of them are a little quicker and some of
them a little slower but roughly around
7 Minutes uh so we'll go ahead and sell
off the white berries and uh well we'll
just inst sell them just for the sake of
the video so we're going to get about
590k as of the current prices so I still
believe that this is one of the most
accessible and profitable early game
money makers especially now that the
prices of white berries have gone up
roughly to about 1.3k each definitely
making it viable again um so it's 600k
an hour roughly and this can be done at
on the level three honestly if you
wanted although I would recommend you
get 25 HP and um but that's pretty much
it so you guys enjoyed and I will see
you guys in the next
[Music]
video